guess what
navi won another tournament i know
absolute shocker isn't it but while
simple continues to absolutely boss it
there are other things to talk about
here the blast premiere world final also
gave us some soon to rebuilt teams
playing out of their actual minds as
well as possibly one of the spiciest
transfer rumors of the year
that turned out not to be true at all
let's get into it
[Music]
all right before we get into today's
video josh is going to share a few words
now from our friends over at predator
gaming
[Music]
hey what's up guys it's josh bury from
thescore esports and this is my holiday
gift guide while it's important to
always be comfortable when you're at
your desk there are only so many hours i
can spend there before i need a change
of scenery but i don't want to sacrifice
performance when i'm on the go
thankfully our friends at predator
gaming have my back sporting an intel
11th gen h-series core i7 processor and
an nvidia geforce rtx 3050 ti gpu the
predator triton 300se lets me play final
fantasy 14 wherever i happen to be at
that moment you can find one of these
bad boys at your local best buy
[Music]
so 2021 will be known as the year lands
returned to cs go and also the year of
navi and the recent blast premier world
finals in copenhagen was a fitting end
to it all as the final tournament of the
year just a week ago we had the upper
bracket quarter-finals where na'vi were
shockingly knocked down into the lower
bracket by team liquid perfecto and
simple two on four to try and reclaim
the round and it looks absolutely
impossible stewie is listening calling
it yep they're both passed by they know
everything right now liquid coming out
of nowhere with no one expecting any
kind of a win and they take down na'vi
16-7 and win the series
absolutely spectacular work for team
liquid i mean this was surprising for
two reasons one because navi have
literally won every lan event they've
attended this year but also too because
team liquid weren't exactly going
through the best time they hadn't
practiced together for a while and there
was a huge roster overhaul just on the
horizon with stewie grimm and fallen all
rumored to be leaving the team after
this tournament some people saw this
tournament as a bit of a write-off for
them elijah and naf were reported to be
the only remaining members after this
tournament a few weeks before the
tournament elijah confirmed the rumors
and also explained why the breakup was
happening it's just pretty much because
like we knew that we're going to be
making changes it's not going to be like
our roster that we're going to be
sticking with and team doesn't really
get along and no it's not just me
against everyone
it is like internally like just everyone
doesn't really get along that well it's
also been reported by one pvs now that
in the absence of stewie and co nitro
who was recently let go by hundreds of
thieves valorem team will be returning
to his old team in cs go the same report
also suggests that shocks will be
leaving vitality to also join liquid so
the question is is na getting the band
back together are the boys well and
truly back in town so yeah pretty insane
start to a tournament if you ask me the
favorites being knocked down to the
lower bracket by a team that's literally
breaking up and in the words of one of
their own players doesn't really get
along that well
ouch but i guess whatever the game or
sport sometimes the teams with nothing
to lose pull off the greatest
performances the same thing kind of
happened with team vitality at the
tournament they were also reported to be
going through a major roster shuffle but
still managed to sweep both astralis and
g2 on their way to the upper bracket
final while liquid did fall to gambit in
the next round navi righted the ship on
their lower bracket run only dropping a
single map as they climbed their way up
to the grand final there they met gambit
who immediately showed them on map one
that they weren't [ __ ] around and
beat the best team in the world on their
own map pick ancient was map two and
although it did feel closer down the
stretch navi answered quickly and took
the map thanks to some ridiculous plays
from bit who continues to show why he's
basically baby simple
close on the ak good spray
shiro love to follow it up but yep he
has the bomb he drops it on the ground
which is probably good don't want to be
giving too much information away ben is
just doing awe work he's just won the
round on his own but it really felt like
na'vi was saving the best till last
because map three saw them absolutely
smash gambit on inferno simple put on a
master class to finish out what's been
an incredible year for him and a team
whose era we are now undisputedly living
in and while simple is rightfully
dominating a lot of the conversation
around navi if you're a forward thinking
fan you're probably thinking of bit
after rising up the ranks in navi jr
last year this homegrown wonder kid has
done nothing but impress his stats are
off the chart he's earned over a million
dollars this year and he's still just 18
years old he's also now four for four on
lan as a pro
wow it was a sick tournament that had a
nice mix of the expected and the
surprising na'vi were definitely the
favorites going into this but how they
got to the final was certainly
surprising and as usual with these kinds
of tournaments sometimes the biggest
news comes right after they finish
yesterday a joint report by dexerto and
onepv suggested that the great dane that
his device is looking to once again don
the australis jersey and return to his
former team now i'm sure i don't need to
go into too much detail about how big of
a deal this is for a lot of cs go fans
device and astralis are still really
linked in their minds they just fit the
cs go community was stirring after the
report that is until device himself
weighed in on twitter let's just jump
back now and give some context to this
whole thing device had legendary success
with astralis for five years starting in
2016. on that legendary roster he won
four majors during that time and still
shares the record with simple for the
most hltv mvps that era came to an end
though in april this year when device
announced he'd be leaving astralis to
join nip for a rumored price just shy of
a million dollars at the time device
said that living in sweden speaking the
language and finding nip's project to be
exciting were some of the reasons for
the change there was also a feeling
among the community that after years of
winning everything with astralis maybe
he just wanted a change of scenery but
not everyone could have predicted that
the biggest change would be just how
little winning he would do for the
remainder of this year when device made
the transfer to nip he said that he was
excited to bring the pgl stockholm
trophy back to sweden but his team only
managed a deflated fifth to eighth
finish at that tournament during intel
extreme masters winter at the start of
the month device admitted on twitter
that he was going through a rough patch
the following week he was subbed out for
nips academy player fizzy after feeling
unwell this illness continued and nip
confirmed that device would not be
attending blast premiere on doctor's
orders so people were wondering whether
or not the rumors were true and why
device had taken a step back from the
team well yesterday he set the record
straight on twitter in a thread he said
my mental health has taken a hammering
this year for both personal reasons and
the pressure that comes with playing
professional esports nip and my
teammates have been very understanding
in letting me work on my mental
well-being for the end of the year i
have been taking active steps towards
recovery and i'm looking forward to
putting in the work that will enable me
to get back to the top of my game and be
the best version of myself all of these
nonsense reports on me leaving the team
are exactly that nonsense when anyone is
having issues surrounding the health of
their mind i believe that it's
imperative they're given time and space
to deal with them and not be bombarded
with falsities so after weeks of
speculation device has snuffed out the
rumors of his return to astralis and has
shed some light on his current situation
both professionally and personally
listen it's not all that often that pros
talk so candidly like this especially
about their own mental health and
honestly it's refreshing all right guys
that is most likely a wrap for us
talking about cs go for the remainder of
2021 here on don't at me but hey
you never know the last tournament might
be over but cs go is always full of
surprises if there are i'll see you soon
but if not happy new year and i'll see
you all in 2022.
hello editor how are you
colton
how are you carlton i'm doing good danny
thanks for asking
and
thanks for remembering my name so 2021
will be known as the yeared landsra
the lands
did i put the land do you put the lands
the what that lands before time
same look
same mug
same mug different day huh but
i'll see you up at the um
i don't know where where people meet
northern ontario the town hall
i'll see you over there bud same day
different [ __ ] huh
you stole fizzy lifting drinks you
bumped into the ceiling which now has to
be washed so you get nothing you lose
good day sir